-There are more than
10 million species
of plant and animals
alive today.
♪♪
And, yet, they are just 1%
of all species
that have ever existed.
♪♪
By traveling back in time,
we'll meet many of the 99%
that have gone extinct.
[ Animal growls softly ]
-Welcome back to "Late Night."
We're here with Morgan Freeman,
everybody!
[ Cheers and applause ]
That was a clip
from "Life on Our Planet."
This shows us --
-Great show.
It's a wonderful show.
It makes you appreciate
being alive when you see
how this world of ours
has developed
over billions of years.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
And if we're not careful...
-It does.
You know, it sort of
is a nice thing to watch
where you realize
that climate change
could take this all
away from us.
Is that something
when you get involved
with a project like this --
do you enjoy that
it's not just
the wonder of the world...
-Oh. Absolutely.
Absolutely, Seth.
Um...
We're in such a...
flux here
in terms of our existence
on this planet.
Let's not think that
we're here to stay just because.
We can see.
If 99% of all life
that has ever lived is gone...
and only 1% is left...
we ought to think about that.
It's like...
well, this planet does things.
[ Laughter ]
It's like --
And there's no place to go.
-That's true.
-Absolutely no place to go.
So we better be careful!
-That's a good --
That's a good warning.
You know, in the clip,
it showed, you know,
dinosaurs, prehistoric life,
and you have to do
a narration about that.
And I'm wondering --
I thought I knew
how to say
all the dinosaurs' names,
but then I have kids, and they
have their dinosaur books,
and I realize I only know
sort of the top three.
-Yeah, me too.
-And then they get
pretty tricky.
Is that something --
Do you get a --
I mean, I'm assuming
you get a bunch of takes,
but are you good with those
words you've never seen before?
-Let me not brag about
what I shouldn't be
trying to brag about.
-You are --
You are a humble man.
And you are also --
We were talking backstage.
You live in the country now.
You live on the Gulf Coast.
-Yes.
Well, it's not "the country."
-Oh.
I didn't mean it to be rude.
-Well --
-You have stores and stuff?
[ Laughter ]
-Restaurants.
-Restaurants?!
-Yeah.
-Okay. I was thinking
of a different thing.
-Yeah. Right.
But I have a home
in Mississippi also.
-Gotcha.
-Pretty much where --
I grew up in Mississippi.
Raise there.
And so I live there.
But it's just a farm,
and it's --
That's the country.
-That's the country.
When did it dawn on you?
Did you think
through your whole life
that at one point you would
find your way back there?
Or was it as you --
as you got older, you thought,
"Oh, you know what,
I like that."
-No, it was not until
about 1983.
My parents had moved back.
And I started visiting them
maybe once a year or so.
And every time I went there,
I was like, "Oh.
This is so relaxing.
This is so nice.
This is...'
So by 1989 or '90...
we decided, alright,
we'll build here.
-Are people happy to see you
back home in Mississippi?
-Always. Yeah.
-Yeah, I would hope so.
At, like, the stores
and the restaurants?
-See that?
-What is that? S-I-P?
-That's The Sip.
-What's The Sip?
-That's --
-Oh, that's Mississippi!
-Yeah! Yo!
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Now...
I just want you to know I would
never have the confidence
to say to you,
"How's The Sip? Is it good?
Are things in The Sip good?"
But now I'm gonna --
Next time you come here,
I'm gonna say it.
-Okay. We're moving right along.
-Alright. I'm glad.
-Yeah.
Moving all the way
into the 20th century.
-There we go.
-Yeah.
It's certainly easier to spell.
Um...
I want to ask about another
documentary you produced
about --
It was -- What was it called?
"The 761st..."
-It was -- Yeah.
The 761st Tank Battalion.
The Black Panthers.
This was the first
armored battalion, Black,
to be engaged in the war --
World War II.
Um...Patton.
-And did you know much
about them?
I know you served
in the Air Force.
Was this something
you'd ever heard about?
-No. I had -- A guy came to us.
I have a company.
You know, we make movies.
-You produce stuff.
-Produce stuff, you know?
Revelations Entertainment.
And the guy came to us
with this project.
It was a script about
the 761st Tank Battalion.
I did not know anything
about that.
So, of course, you can Google it
and find out everything
you need to know now.
Um, so then -- I don't know.
But this goes back
to 20, 25 years maybe...
-Okay.
-...that we've had this project.
So it's like...
nothing good comes easy.
And then -- I don't know.
As things developed,
we were able to make
a very, very nice documentary
about them.
But I want to make a series
to get them out into...
-Yeah. Sort of a "Band of
Brothers" situation, right?
-Exactly.
Exactly what I want to do.
-I think that's a very
safe pair of hands.
I hope you can get that
for us all to see.
There's a wonderful book
about it, as well,
called "Come Out Fighting."
I'm assuming
this is one of these...
-Yeah, we used that.
That's part of our background,
our research.
-There you go.
-Yeah.
-Alright. Well, it's just
a joy to have you back.
Thank you so much.
What a pleasure.
-It's a joy to sit here
and talk to you.
-Morgan Freeman, everybody.
"Life on Our Planet"
is streaming now on Netflix.
We'll be right back
with McKay Coppins.